ouais le rapport à ma communauté il a
changé euh parce que quand tu prends de
de l'importance sur Internet et ça il y
a beaucoup de gens qui s'en rendent pas
compte sur Internet euh notamment des
influenceurs tu as un tu as un ascendant
gen les gens psychologique qui est pas
bien j'en ai fait les frais aussi euh
dans j'ai été euh voilà j'ai été victime
d'ascendant psychologique sur Internet
aussi euh et euh il faut faire très
attention voilà moi du coup je j'ai
décidé de prendre une distance par
rapport à ma
communauté ma communauté sont des gens
qui regardent mes vidéos et j'ai décidé
de pas être dans la proximité avec eux
ça marche à moitié je suis pas encore
trop satisfait de ma manière de le de le
discerner parce que finalement tous les
gen une partie de mon travail c'est
aussi de nourrir des relations
parasociales et j'aimerais que ce soit
pas le cas j'aimerais que mes vidéos
soient prises dans un vide mais c'est
impossible et aussi parce que je suis un
un mec sensible et du coup je je parle
beaucoup de comment des trucs m'ont
impacté et cetera et que je suis très
vocal sur ça dans dans fining parce que
bah encore une fois j'écris pas comme
s'il y avait des gens qui qui allaient
me m'écouter du moins pas beaucoup du
coup c'est c'est une balance compliquée
que je vais essayer de mieux gérer je
peux pas me permettre de d'être pote
comme j'ai pu l'être avec tous mes
abonnés une période où j'étais trop
content ouais j'ai enfin des amis
j'étais très seul quand j'étais
petit bonjour à tous C'est fel DUP salut
tout le monde c'est fdup j'ai toujours
tendance à dire regarder la vidéo en
entier ce texte décrit donc cette
hypothèse selon laquelle on pourrait
traverser la réalité elle-même le
findings numéro 1 qui m'a lancé un peu
dans l'algorithme et aujourd'hui il a
pas tellement de vu que ça mais c'est le
finding sur Andrew gozdon un enfant qui
a disparu au Royaume-Uni c'est simple je
je comprends pas du tout ce qui se passe
dans cette dans cette histoire elle
apparaît le 20 janvier 2019 dans les
recommandés de plein de gens et d'un
coup je me souviens je me réveille alors
que ma chaîne était stagnée à à 5000
6000 abonnés depuis depuis 2 ans d'un
coup je gagne 1000 abonnés en un jour
genre ensuite il y a eu la vidéo sur FL
1815 FL 1812 pardon m'en souvenz plus
attends c'est long j'ai trouvé cet
appareil photo Canon 11d sous un abribus
vers les but de chumon àr Armand Carel
et ainsi s'ens su un mystère qui va
s'étaufer à chaque poste réalisé par ce
compte Twitter après il eu la vidéo sur
Elan School qui est encore aujourd'hui
ma vidéo la plus vue je crois
laissez-moi vous parler de l'école la
plus controversée de l'histoire la plus
violente vous expliquz son histoire qui
l' fondé pourquoi elle était aussi
violente et enfin j'essaierai de vous
expliquer pourquoi elle a continué à
subsister pendant 41 ans et Elan school
c'était le moment de la véritable
explosion ça a été posté pendant un des
confinements je crois et je me souviens
que c'était une période de 2 mois où
j'ai gagné 100000 ou 200000 abonnés
quand le confinement s'est terminé il y
a eu vraiment le jour et la nuit
j'allais dehors les gens me
reconnaissaient avant ça arrivait pas et
c'est d'un coup c'est monté de pression
et ca et tout je me rends pas forcément
compte du nombre de gens qui regardent
mes vidéos et je peux me donner une
image de moi-même qui est pas
forcément la la plus juste je suis pas
un mec qui regarde des trucs terrifiants
tout le temps je j'ai j'ai une vie
ordonnée et je fais juste du travail
documentaire en
2021222 j'ai fait un focus sur un des
sujets cétait la curiosité morbide c'est
normal d'avoir de la curiosité morbide
comment est-ce qu'on peut expurger ça de
manière de
manière comment dire contrôlé estce que
c'est normal d'en avoir par contre il y
a des manières plus saines de la souvir
qu'autre chose et le problème c'est que
ça a créé une attente les gens m'ont
tout de suite vu comme le mec hardcore
alors que non la vérité c'est que non ça
me fait rire parfois de jouer sur cette
image mais en vrai à partir de 2023 j'ai
enfin j'ai décidé de stopper un peu ce
genre de sujet déjà parce que Ben au
bout d'un moment parler tout le temps de
de de criminel pédophile parler tout le
temps de de de de meurtre inf femme de
de de vrais sujet de société moi aussi
ça m'attend et du coup où je remarque
qu'il y a pas forcément cette attente je
je sens pas une pression de parler de
trucs extrême
euh donc ça va mais je sens que je suis
attaché à cette image et que c'est un
peu aussi de ma faute hein je que ce
soit parce que j'ai traité des sujets
avec parfois avec un peu de maladresse
euh notamment au début des findings
parfois j'ai été maladroit tu vois je
pense notamment il y a eu une trilogie
de vidéo que j'avais fait autour de 2022
début 2022 c'était sur la face cachée de
Youtube je parlais de 3 cas de de de
youtubeurs qui chacun
avait vécu ou fait des choses horribles
et dans ces vidéoslà mon propos était
pas clair et ça sonnait sensationaliste
et du coup j'ai beaucoup réfléchi depuis
j'essaie de me poser des questions quand
même sur mon mon traitement est-ce qu'il
est juste donc en soit ça ça a changé ma
manière d'écrire c'est vrai je dirais
que le truc que je retiens de de faire
des trucs sur Internet c'est ça rien à
voir avec tout ce que j'ai dit c'est
euh de pas trop parler de soi en fait ça
c'est mon c'est mon plus gros regret
d'internet c'est quand j'étais au
collège et au lycée que j'allais pas
bien je parlais tout le temps de comment
ça allait pas bien partout sur les
réseaux depuis c'est devenu une arme
pour qu'on peut utiliser contre moi dans
le sens on peut l'utiliser pour me pour
me faire du mal au-delà de ça je dirais
que c'est important de se rendre compte
de de l'influence qu'on a très tôt de
comment
euh du fait que on s'adresse à des gens
qui te voient pas forcément comme un
comme un comme un être humain mais comme
une sorte d'entité un truc un truc
différent pourquoi on aime se faire peur
sur Inter inter c'est quoi ce frisson
pourquoi on recherche le frisson c'est
un c'est complètement psychologique et
c'est normal c'est humain le cerveau
aime pas l'imprévu du coup pour enlever
tout ce qui est pour enlever tout ce qui
est imprévu et cetera il aime bien se
placer dans des scénarios stressants
dans des trucs et cetera pour être sûr
d'être prêt au pire je pense enfin je
crois que c'est un truc comme ça qui qui
qui fonctionne tu apprends à avoir moins
peur dans le futur si jamais il se passe
un truc grave si tu regardes un truc qui
fait peur de manière contrôlée je pense
aussi que l'attrait de l'horreur c'est
aussi l'attrait du mystère et moi c'est
ça ce qui me fascine le plus en réalité
c'est le mystère c'est la frustration
que pose que que pose un mystère non
élucidé vous n'auriez jamais dû prendre
cet appareil photo comment voulez-vous
que je vous restitue l'appareil si vous
avez trouvé ce numéro c'est trop tard
pour l'appareil c'est quoi le compte
àbourg vous avez désormais des problèmes
qui vont arriver bien avant la fin du
comptearbour il y a plein de raisons
différentes pour laquell on pourrait
regarder de l'horreur pour regarder
l'horreur euh par exemple des des
documentaires criminels on garde ça
euh parfois par curiosité malsine
parfois
aussi pour l'information et se dire ça
peut arriver voilà comment les choses se
sont passées c'est pour ça que je me
focalise toujours sur
euh du moins j'essaie sur le sur le vécu
des victimes dans ce genre de situation
et aussi sur comment s passé l'enquête
montrer comment les enquêteurs sont
parfois très bons ou parfois des billes
complètes regarder un contenu sur un
mystère d'Internet ça peut aussi être
pour ouvrir son esprit fantastique juste
c'est c'est c'est fascinant de voir des
des des gens qui euh des gens qui
construisent des mystères non élucidés
les tout ce qui est cikada 3301 des
énormes jeux de piss on n jamais eu
l'explication de pourquoi ça c'est juste
humain on
a on a envie d'avoir des informations
qui ont des informations manquantes
juste pour le la satisfaction de le de
remplir les information manquante
jusqu'à ce qu'on se rend compte que
c'est que parfois il y en a pas et que
ça c'est encore plus fascinant je sais
pas moi il y a plein de raisons pour
lesquelles l'horreur c'est
fascinant